Bu konuşmanın başlığını ben nasıl
delirdim demediğim için kendime şaşırdım
Biraz önce otururken aklıma geldi izin
ver dünyalar senin olsun demiştim
Aslında bu da çok anlamlı Ama biraz da
nasıl delirdiğimi de anlatacağım size
biraz sonra
38 yıldır o kadar yazarım ki bana bu
konuşmadan öncesinde Hazır mısın diye
soranlar oldu gerçekten çok hazırım bir
gün burada konuşacağımız zaten
biliyordum emindim ve Aslında neredeyse
hiçbir hazırlık yapmadım Sadece
Kafamdaki düşünceleri biraz toparlamaya
çalıştım bütün Kağıt doldu
çok doluyum ama bir taraftan da bomboşum
Tamamen kendimi boşalttım arkadaşlar
burada artık gelen neyse onu aktaracağım
size dertlerim çok fazla
psikolog paraları da çok pahalı O yüzden
burada beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
ediyorum
çok güzel bir konuşma olacak Onu Garanti
edebilirim size güleceğiz belki
ağlayacağız diyar diyar gezeceğiz Ama en
çok da düşüneceğiz
Yalnız şöyle düşünüyorum bir ağacın
meyvesi için nasıl bir kök bir gövde
dallar vesaire hepsi bir seferber olup
da O meyveyi yukarıda tutuyorsa Aslında
an da böyle benim geçirdiğim bütün
hayatım bugüne kadar sadece bu an içinde
ve bu an için ve bu an için hepimiz için
bu alana çok değerli yapan bir şey değil
mi
dediğim gibi çok güzel bir konuşma
olacak öncesinde şunu görmek istiyorum
Burada kimler kendini güzel buluyor
Vallahi hiç fena değil çok iyi Peki
soruyu değiştiriyorum şu anda kimler
güzel olduğunu biliyor
Evet biraz değişti
fena değiliz daha eminiz Aslında şimdi
bu iki sorunun şöyle bir farkı var bir
tanesi Eril bir soru bir tanesi yeşil
bir soru çok konuşuluyor Bu arada
erilişiyle enerji
Eril olan Hep merak eder arkadaşlar
analiz eder kıyaslar zanların içine
girer ve Dışarıda hep bir otorite Arar
dişi ise ben güzelim deyip çıkar işin
içinden zaten çoğunuzu görmüyorum
gözlerim çok net değil o yüzden rahat
olabilirsiniz eli kaldırırken Kimileri
böyle şeyler yaptı böyle arada kalanlar
oldu yılan dansı yapanlar oldu falan
Arkadaşlar biz güzeliz bu kadar daha
ötesi yok bu işte eminliktir eminlik
emanetten gelir Biz bir kendimize emanet
olduğumuzu eminliğimizden biliriz kelime
kökü olarak biliyorsunuz
Evet Dünya çok Ehil bir sistemin içinde
ve biz kendimizi Aslında yakalamakta
zorlanıyoruz ve zihinlerimiz o kadar
bizi yönetiyor ki
günlük hayatımızda sürekli çok yoğun bir
zihinsel aktivitenin içindeyiz sürekli
bir şeyleri zannediyoruz sürekli bir
şeyleri kıyaslıyoruz bir çoğunuz Biraz
önce Belki de kendini güzel olan
birileriyle kıyasladı işte modellerle
Angelina Öyleyse ya da Öyleyse ben de
şöyleyeyim falan ya da çevremizde belki
çirkin bulduğumuz bir insan vardı onunla
kıyasladık o Öyleyse ben daha güzelim ya
fena değilim falan diye veya dışarıda
otorite arıyoruz bugün birçok insan
dolgu yaptırıyor dolgular Bilmem zaten
botoks yaptırmaya dövüyorlar
biliyorsunuz
acayip bir dışarıda otorite arama peşine
girdik Herkes bir güzellik tanımlıyor ve
onu biz ona uymaya çalışıyoruz
şimdi böyle bir sistem içinde
kendimize dönmemiz şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
bu adam sürdürülebilirlik vesaire
konuşuyordu ama nereden gelecek bunları
zaten biraz sonra açıklayacağım buna çok
netleşecek her şey birçoğunuz zanlar
içinde yaşıyorsunuz aslında kendi
hikayemi anlatıyorum
zor bir çocukluk geçirdim psikolojik
olarak ve kendi Hikayem derken aslında
bu hepimizin de hikayesi
şimdi çocuk annesinden Bağlarını
koparmaya başladığı anda Küçük yaşlarda
kendisine dışarıda bir otorite arar ki
tekrardan annesine kavuşabilmek için bu
babası olabilir veya başka biri olabilir
onun hareketlerini örnek alır onun
düşüncelerini kanun olarak kabul eder bu
bizim dışarıda affettiğimiz ilk
otoritedir süperego dediğimiz şey önce
babamız veya çevremizdeki o annemize
yakın olan kişiyle Ondan sonra
çevremizde örnek aldığımız insanlarla
oluşur ve bu otorite daha sonra baba
patron öğretmen müdür devlet başkanı
vesaire vesaire gider
sizinle arkadaşlar birkaç saat temel
özelliğe sahiptir
bir tanesi zanneder şu anda Mesela bugün
buraya arabayla gelenler vardır büyük
ihtimalle hepinizin arabalarınızın
otoparkta falan olduğunu zannediyorsunuz
Mesela bu Bizans şu anda gerçekten Emin
değilsiniz
veya Biraz önce söylediğim gibi
kıyaslamalar yapıyorsunuz Ben de
çocukluğumdan itibaren
Belki de
ebeveynlerinden sevgi dilini doğrudan
beklediğim gibi göremediğim için aslında
dil çok önemli burada çünkü biz bazen
sevilmediğimizi zannederiz Ama bazen
Mesela okşanmak isteriz Ama orada
annemiz bize yemek yaparak sevgisini
gösteriyordur ve biz bu zamlarla
büyümeye başlarız işte ben de böyle
zanlarla kendini sevilmemiş gören falan
bir çocuk gibi zannederek
büyüme çağına girdim Ve tabii ki birçok
zanna sahip oldum
Bunlar nelerdir zamanı yakalamak MEB
hiçbir zaman boş zaman geçirme
zannederken aşırı doldurup aşırı
telaşlanmaya başladıktan itibaren şunu
gördüm ki
Aslında derinleşmediğim her an kayıp Ben
zaten bütün zamanımı kaybediyorum O
zaman gerçekten derinleşmediğim zaman
veya her şey dışarıda zannederiz işte
fizik kimya biyolojik bütün pozitif
bilimler vesaire sanki dışarıda
zannediyorsam Oysa Aslında bunların
hepsi içimizdedir veya sahip olduğumuzu
zannederiz işte çevre temizliklere
malımızdan büyükümüze sevdiklerimize
Hatta kendimize bile Arkadaşlar biraz
önce söylediğim gibi biz sadece bize
emanetiz kendimize bile Sahip değiliz o
yüzden rahatlayın sahip olmamak çok
rahat bir duygudur o kadar
rahatlayacaksınız ki Gerçekten bunu
hissettiğiniz zaman
şimdi Tabii yol arayışına giriştim
çocukluktan itibaren işte Galatasaray
Lisesi ODTÜ bilmem ne falan acayip böyle
proje çocuk gibi yetiştiriliyorum ama
bir eksiklik var ben kendimi arıyorum
İnşaat Mühendisliği okudum Teknik bir
tarafa girdim ama aslında o kadar teknik
diye bir adam değilim yani iki lafı bir
araya getirebiliyorum yazabiliyorum
çizebiliyorum da falan Tabii
Galatasaray'ın da verdi bize böyle bir
şey var Sen süpersin Aslansın kaplansın
falan
şimdi İnşaat mühendisliğini bitirdim ama
ben acayip doğayı falan da seviyorum
böyle ormanda yürümeyi böceklerle şey
yapmayı falan filan Ondan sonra bu İkisi
birleşti ben de bunları nasıl
birleştirildiğini bu zihinsel
birleştirdim
ekolojik yapılar Sürdürülebilir şehirler
doğal binalar enerji verimli vesaire çok
güzel böyle çok tatmin oldu burada
ofsaydım tamam süper Türkiye'de de bu
işe ilk girenlerden bir tanesi Yaklaşık
15 sene önce o zaman esamesi okunmuyordu
biz
müteahhitlerin yanına gittiğimiz zaman
ben Tabi o zaman bir firmalarda
çalışıyorum danışmanlık firmalarında
Koskoca Müteahhitler böyle kendi Fellah
metrekareye alırız şurada beton atacağız
şuraya bilmem ne yapacağız falan Sen ne
yapıyorsun delikanlı falan dedikleri
zaman ekoloji
yapılır Hani çevreye duyarlar
böyle konuşmayı anlatmaya çalışıyorum
konuyu Tamam neyse sen işine bak falan
deyip geçiştiriyorlar o zamanlar
böyleydi Biz o zamanlar talep ediyorduk
bakın binanızı şöyle yapın da biraz daha
iyileştirin falan gibi
şimdi onlar geliyor şimdi büyük binalar
işte büyük inşaat şirketleri biz nasıl
daha çevreci yapabiliriz daha işte
ekonomik yapabiliriz falan filan gibi
tabi biraz daha korkuyla vesaire
Fakat ben kendimi anlatmak Gerçekten çok
zorlandım hep necisindeyim hem kendim
soruyorum Bunu kendime hem de başkaları
soruyorum sen necisin kardeşim
eşimin en zor kısmı kendi yaptığım işi
anlatmaktı gerçekten işini kendisi daha
kolaydı yani
fakat Şunu fark ettim hiçbir konuda
birbirinden izole değil biz özellikle
Batı uygarlığı hep konulara böyle Tabii
zihinde böyle çalıştığı için hep
kalıplara koyalım bu böyledir şu
şöyledir bu alanlar birbirinden
bağımsızdır gibi lan dedim ekoloji böyle
bir şey değil
ya psikoloji diye bir şey var psikoloji
bilimim arkadaşlar
onun bilimi ruh bilimi var Sen nasıl
ruhu dışarıda bırakabilirsin Ben Ee ne
zaman yolum değişti bu uzun süre gitti
böyle ekolojik yapılar vesaire Ama bir
eksik var onu hissediyorum Hayatımda tam
böyle Ayaklarımı yerden kesen bir iş yok
Ne zaman ki Üniversitede ders vermeye
başladım of dedim tamam Bu benim işim
acayip mutluyum böyle heyecanlıyım böyle
aktarmayı Bayılıyorum şu anda olduğu
gibi
çıkıyorum böyle konuşuyorum ama birikim
varmış birikim var onu hissediyorum yani
acayip eminlik de var kendimde
ve o zaman dedim ki bu benim işim
gerçekten ben aktarmayı çok seviyorum
işte ekolojik yapılarla birleştirdim
Tamam doğayla da birleştirdim ama şimdi
bunu aktarması Peki İşte bu aktarma
başladıktan sonra şunu farkettim ki
konular birbirinden izole değil Ben
ekolojinin şöyle bir şey olduğunu fark
ettim bir noktadan sonra bireysel
alışkanlıklar çok önemli Arkadaşlar biz
kendimize dönmeden istediğiniz kadar
sistem getirin istediğiniz kadar ürün
getirin
Sürdürülebilir yakalamamız mümkün değil
hiçbir kalıba mesleğe sığmamamız
gerekiyor bakın
doktorluk diyorsunuz araştırma yapmayı
mı seviyorsun konferans vermeyi mi
seviyorsun hastayı ameliyat etmeyi mi
seviyorsun hastayla iletişim kurmayı mı
seviyorsun Hangi tarafı o kadar spesifik
ki bunlar hepsini ayrı ayrı ele almamız
lazım biraz uğraştı tespit olmamız lazım
bugün üniversite eğitimi maalesef
öğrencileri de söylüyorum Çok maalesef
onların hallerine de biraz acıyorum
adamlar en enerjik olması gereken
çağlarda hepsi böyle hayattan bezmiş
durumda benden daha bezmişler sınıfa
gidiyorum böyle yerlerde yatanlar
Uyuyanlar falan
sınıfta bunu yapıyorum Bu arada daha
fazla farklı bir şey yapmıyorum burada
biliyorlar bazıları geldi sanırım bakın
el kaldırın bir göreyim sizi ha işte
buradalar Evet Oo daha fazlasıyla gelmiş
süper çok seviyorum onları
fakat dediğim gibi yani burada
spesifik olmamız gerekiyor Ben neyi
seviyorum gerçekten arkadaşlar
sevmediğin işi yapanların hiç kimseye
hayır gelmez kendine de başkasına da
ve sürdürülebilirlik de budur Aslında
verimlilik de budur başka bir şey
değildir yani gerisi hepsi zaman kaybı
kendimi bilmem gerekiyor önce kendimi
bilmezsem Ben neyi bilebilirim ki
kendini bebek kolay bir şey değil böyle
laf atıyor atıyorum ortaya Ama tabii ki
bu bir uğraş kendinle ilgili gayret
etmek gerekiyor
fakat bütüncül bakmak çok önemli bugün
biraz önce bahsettiğim gibi önce
bizi kalıplara sokan bilim zihniyeti
Şimdi tekrar bütüncülüğü keşfetmeye Biz
zaten bütüncülük biz bundan 400-5 yıl
önce Zaten 500 yıl önce bütüncülük
Arkadaşlar biri hastalandığında aşamalı
geliyordu otçusu geliyordu enerjisiz
geliyordu dinlenmesi gerekiyor dualar
okunuyordu falan
olay çözülüyordu
sonra bir ne oldu bir koptuk böyle
kendimizden bir Zihni aşırı düştük işte
zihnimizi yönetemedik zihin bizi yönetti
Ondan sonra her şeyi bir ayırdık bu şu
ayrılır bu Bunda ayrılır falan E şimdi
ne oldu Tekrar bütüncülüğe gelmeye
başladık bu her konuda böyle
Sürdürülebilir yapılarda da böyle yani
biz 50 yıl öncesine kadar arkadaşlar
bütün yapılarımız sürdürülebilirdi Bizim
Köy evlerimizde doğal malzemelerden
kullanıyorduk vesaire şimdi ne oldu
yeşil bile Oo sanki yepyeni bir keşifmiş
gibi yeni bir keşif falan değil biz
unuttuğumuz şey tekrar bize satılıyor
arkadaşlar bunlara uyanalım
an çok önemli kendini bilmek önemli Umut
Umut'a ihtiyacımız yok Herkes diyor ya
Umut falan ya kendini bakın anında çok
güzel yaşayan dolu dolu yaşayan anda
mevcut olan bir insanın umutlanma
ihtiyacı yok ki Umut zihnin ihtiyacı
Çünkü neden Ben şu anki Halime kötü
görüyorum ya da dünyayı kötü görüyorum o
zaman hep Umut hep gelecek hep bir
beklenti Ummak Böyle bir şeye ihtiyacım
yok dünyanın ne zaman güzelleşecek
biliyor musunuz siz dünyayı güzel
görmeye başladığınız zaman güzelleşecek
dünya hep böyle gidecek Arkadaşlar siz
güzel göreceksiniz o güzel görmeyi
öğrenmesi öğrenmeniz gerekiyor
inanca da ihtiyacımız yok inanç da
zenginliği için ben hiçbir şeye
inanmıyorum
tasavvufla falan çok ilgilenirim sufizme
de girerim bunun tasavvufun içinde inanç
yoktur Bugün Bize öğretilen her şey bin
yıllardır da inanç değil aslında biz
inanmışız Çünkü bilmiyoruz Emin
olmadığımız şey inanırız arkadaşlar Emin
olduğumuz şeyi bildiğimiz şeyi zaten
inanmaya ihtiyaç duymayız
şimdi ne oldu ben böyle işte Hem
anlatmayı seven hem şeyleri seven işte
ekolojiyi vesaire böyle strate stand-up
gibi bir şey oldum ben kendimi biraz
öyle tanımıyorum şimdi Ben illa bir
tanım isteyene böyle tanımıyorum kendimi
ve Kafamdaki o babayla kurduğum
zamanında işte zamlarla
zehirlediğim kendimi Ondan sonra sürekli
kıyasladığım zamanlardan çıkıp şu anda
böyle tamamen hafiflediğim acayip
kendimi anlattığım her anımı dolu dolu
Yaşadığım bir sahnede dans edecek
noktaya geldim yani
şöyle bir hikaye var Afrika'da bir
kabile reisi var bir keşifçi de onunla
beraber Afrika'da bazı yerleri keşfetmek
için arkasına takılıp gidiyor Günler
geceler gidiyorlar Ondan sonra kabile
reis Bir gün duruyor ve gitmiyor
keşifçiyse soruyor Neden gitmiyoruz
devam etmiyoruz diye bir dakika diyor
bizim ruhlarımızın bedenimizi yakalama
ihtiyacı var o yüzden biraz ruhlarımızı
bekleyeceğiz şu anda diye arkadaşlar çok
hızlı ve hayatın içindeyiz ruhlarımız
gerçekten geriden geliyor biraz durup
içimizi dinlememiz gerekiyor şimdi
değişik bir deneyim yaşayacağız
ışıkları birazcık azaltalım müziği
verelim
gözlerimizi kapatalım arkadaşlar
ekolojinin ne olduğunu size şu anda
farklı bir şekilde anlatmak istiyorum
[Müzik]
ormanda yürüyorsun
çok güzel sesler ağaçların arasındasın
biraz Alacakaranlık
[Alkış]
ışık ve karanlığın arasında
yavaş yavaş
yürürken ağaçların arasında çok güzel
Işıklı ahşap bir ev görüyorsun
ona doğru yürüyorsun
bahçe kapısı var tahta bir kapağı
içerden çok güzel Işıklar sesler kokular
geliyor
yavaşça kapıyı aralıyorsun o kadar güzel
Işıklar geliyor ki gözlerin kamaşıyor
biraz daha kapıyı aralığında karşında
biri beliriyor bir kişi var
kişi
sensin
Birbirinizin gözlerinin içine bakın
[Müzik]
kendinizi görün
isterseniz saçına omzuna
dokunabilirsiniz
ve şimdi
yavaşça sarılın
kendinize tekrar kavuşuyorsunuz
sıkı sıkı sarın birbirinizi
adeta iç içe geçtiniz ve kendinize
tekrar kavuştunuz hasretle
kucaklıyorsunuz
[Müzik]
Evet
ışıkları tekrar açalım müziği kısalım
kendinize Hoş geldiniz arkadaşlar
ekoloji
ev demektir oykos crackçe ev demektir
Eko ekoloji ev bilimidir Biz önce kendi
evimizden başlayacağız Burası benim
önceki ilk Evim katman katman gidiyoruz
Ondan sonra İçinde bulunduğumuz Mesken
mekan Ondan sonra da gezegen içten dışa
bu ev katmanlarıyla kurduğumuz ilişkide
Koleji ben kendimi bilmeden istediğimiz
kadar dünya batacak bakın 3 tane dünya
yetecek ancak bize yetecek diyorlar 2050
yılında kaynak olarak arkadaşlar Böyle
hareket edemeyiz bununla hareket ederiz
de bunu ancak zihinsel aktivitesi veya
entelektüel düzeyi belli bir seviyede
olan insanlar bunu şey yapar onlar da
kendi çabalarıyla bir yere gelemez
dünyanın bütün dünyayı hitap etmek
istiyorsak bizim korkuyla hareket
etmememiz gerekiyor arkadaşlar korkuyla
atılan hiçbir adamdan hayır gelmez bizim
sevgiyle hareket etmemiz gerekiyor
tekrar kendimize dönmemiz gerekiyor
ekoloji için
enerji tüketiminin
toplam dünyadaki enerji tüketimi %30'u
30'a yakını sadece bireysel tüketim
alışkanlıkları Yani ben Ali'nin Ayşe'nin
Fatma'nın evde aşırı gereksiz yere ışığı
açık bırakması Televizyon açık
bırakmasından kaynaklanıyor
durum böyle iken bizim Önce kendimize
bakmamız lazım belki korkudan açık
bırakıyorlar korkudan açık bırakanlar
var böyle Hikayeler var Bu arada Gece
karanlıkta yalnız kalamıyor falan E
şimdi bu adam Hasan istediğin ürünü
istediğin yeşil binayı yap olmaz
arkadaşlar olmaz Önce kendimize
döneceğiz bakın bir tane daha örnek
vereyim Hiç hava sıcaklığını dünyada
Pardon Türkiye'de hiç ortam hava
sıcaklığını ortalama 25 dereceden 1
derece düşürmek sadece 24 dereceye
düşürmek
sevmeyen tüketir Arkadaşlar biz
ihtiyaçlarımızı bileceğiz kendimize daha
çok döneceğiz
sürdürülebilirlik kaliteli sosyallik
gerektirir kaliteli sosyalleşin sadece
internetten ve sayede değil gerçekten
sevdiğiniz insanlarla birlikte olduğunu
önce kendinizle Ondan sonra bütün
sevdiklerinizle birlikte olun güzel
zamanlar geçirin bugün çünkü sistem bizi
sürekli birbirimizden koparmaya
uzaklaştırmaya çalışabiliyorsunuz yeni
çağda fizik ve metafizik ayrımı artık
kalmadı birkaç gün önce Duyanlar vardır
atom altı parçacıkların eş zamanlı
olarak farklı yerlerde birbirini
etkileştiğini ortaya koyan Bilimsel bir
araştırma bunu kabul etti bile ama neden
olduğunu bilmiyor bilmiyoruz ama böyle
bir şey var dedi ilk defa arkadaşlar
dünyada
kuantum sağ olsun artık ayrımlar kalmadı
bizim çok daha hızlı girdiğimiz bir
döneme girdik kendi farkımız ortaya
çıkardı anlayacağınız bir döneme girdik
kendimizi kendi farkını ortaya
çıkarmayanların maalesef sistemden
silineceği robot işlerini Artık maalesef
robotlara bırakılacağı bir sisteme
girdik esneklik çok önemli yeni nesil
çok daha esnek bir nesil
bugün bizi belki dünyayı yöneten
devletler şunlar bunlar inançların
hiçbiri kalmayacak Belki bu esneklik
sayesinde fakat gençlerin tek bir şeyi
var o da odaklanmak Lütfen odaklanın
arkadaşlar sevdiğiniz işlere
dünya çocukluktan
doğayla birlikten ergenliğe geçti önce
ergenlikle ne yaptık velilerden kopar
gibi dünyadan koptuk şimdi yetişkinliğe
geçiyoruz hem bireyiz hem de Dünya ile
bir olduğumuzu tekrardan insanlık olarak
idrak ettiğimiz bir döneme girdik bize
kendi duanıza izin verin ve konuşmanın
başlığı da buydu dünyalar sizin olsun
hem de o bahsettiğimiz üç dünyada o
zaman sizinle olur Teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]